a lot of nfl news to get to uh that's
why we get the best
to come and educate us here next on the
show joining us from espn
nfl reporter mr jeff darlington jeff
what's going on buddy how you doing
the best that's like when you get your
dad a shirt that says world's best dad
i like it i like it like do you really
mean it
but you know what we'll all take it i'll
run with it well today you know today
today
you know it's it's it's all about
context today you're the best you're the
best today
that uh i am the best yep i'm the best
guest on the rich eisen show at this
moment
exactly and that's what you should
strive to be the best you can be in this
very moment because
it's very very fleeting as we know just
two days ago
we didn't know that aaron rodgers was
going to be the green bay packers
quarterback well
yeah i did i did i've known this for the
whole offseason but
as it transpired are we i mean
what do you expect from this team we've
heard people talk about hey it's a
championship roster
this this fallout's going to have a big
effect on it where where do you think
this green bay packers team goes now
that aaron's back randall cobb fits into
the mix
and ryan gutenkos is flat out you know
being honest hey we signed
randall because it was for aaron that's
what that's what we're doing now
to me the only thing that matters is
aaron rodgers being back
yeah like i personally don't necessarily
believe randall cobb will make some
incredible impact i love randall cobb
i think he's a good player and provides
familiarity with with aaron in this
situation but
to me that's not like like hey this is
the difference between
going to the super bowl and not right to
me
simply getting aaron back i subscribe to
the belief that players are pretty
resilient
even when there's a quarterback who
doesn't go through this type of drama
even if that quarterback doesn't get
along with the whole locker room and i'm
not suggesting that's
the way it is there at all i'm just
saying like in other places
this has happened where there is drama i
always think back whenever there's like
drama and we wonder about chemistry of
the locker room
i always think back to the night before
the seahawks won the super bowl when
percy harvin
and now i don't want to mess this up it
was a golden tate got into a fist fight
right literally the night before the
super bowl
like if that if they can do that and win
the game and win the super bowl i i
kind of subscribe to the belief that
maybe
um maybe a hall of fame quarterback can
come back into his locker room
and perhaps bridge any awkwardness that
might exist
yeah i i would suspect it would have to
be like west side story it would have to
be like the jets and the sharks in the
in the locker room like completely split
down the middle
right um and what's
what one thing that that possibly could
be a divisive factor this year in the
nfl
is whether or not uh your teammates are
being vaccinated you know we've
we've seen a coach in ron rivera speak
out about it and in his defense right
he's
he's a guy who's living in the real
world of having just
overcome cancer and is immune deficient
and he's sensitive to that and is
disappointed but
we've heard coaches talk about it uh
where they're at where they're going how
what kind of competitive advantage and
disadvantage it could be is
is is a vaccinated player whether
uh they are or not could this be a
divisive factor in a locker room down
the stretch
specifically if if you start taking away
game checks from these players
i'd imagine that guys will get well
we'll have those conversations early
enough
to where they can hopefully get through
it and get on the same page
uh and as far as how this impacts the
season
probably to a degree that it did last
year but maybe
you know like where for instance
the teams that were most prepared and
most vigilant about dealing with the
spread
of covet were ultimately the most
successful and that
turned out by and large i think to be
pretty true
you know the bucks are a pretty good
example of that so two were the chiefs
um
but i think in general
i subscribe to the belief that this
won't be that
big of a thing for the nfl uh eventually
we're still talking about a vaccination
rate of
above 80 percent across the league
that's great so
so i it's as much as i understand the
attention that we're placing on it
things are pretty good in the nfl
actually better statistically than
the rest of society and they have a lot
more
rules in place for those who are
unvaccinated to where perhaps it will
address some of the potential spread so
personally i don't think it's going to
have as much of an impact as it did last
year
and last year they were able to get
through a 17-week season yep
exactly uh it was pretty pretty special
what they were able to do a year ago
because a lot of people
in particular didn't think that that
that was a possible possibility um
down in houston right uh um i don't know
if you heard the quote
but uh from randall cobb but he said
people were looking at him like
he just walked out of prison so is it
that bad in houston
is it that bad in houston that it's like
prison for everybody else
is there not a great irony in this that
aaron rodgers
his beef with the organization and his
beliefs that the organization is
subpar in the treatment of players
ultimately led to the acquisition of
randall cobb
who now says that he's so glad to be
with an organization that does not make
him feel imprisoned
yes there is a twisted irony in all this
and maybe uh and maybe green bay isn't
so bad after all
i do sense though that it is pretty bad
in
in houston i mean if you're looking at
30 i mean they're trading away
uh a lot of top tier talent and they're
not really left with very much
so it almost feels honestly to me like
like an expansion club right now in
houston
and and uh i don't know that anybody
would really argue against that at this
point
we're speaking with jeff darlington espn
nfl reporter
uh the houston situation right uh
the texans have finally said that they
are
are listening to offers with all of the
allegations that are hanging over the
head of deshaun watson
is there is there anything that houston
can get
that's going to be a viable option for
him i mean how does this how does this
all play out he's there
he's at the practice field he's not
being fined i mean this this just
compounds the chaos that exists
for the texans uh yeah i don't get the i
don't i don't get anybody even
reporting or suggesting that the houston
texans
could trade deshaun watson at this point
nor do i understand the fan bases
whether it's philadelphia or miami
where you have these fans who are like
man well i'd love to make a trade for
deshaun watson
you're trading for a guy with 22 civil
lawsuits against him
even if you just completely
don't look at any of the current
evidence that has been sort of
publicized by
the the those alleging these civil
lawsuits and
placing them on even if you just
discount all of the evidence that those
people have brought forward
it's still even if he's completely
innocent of everything that he is
alleged to have done
this is still going to take time it
still is not going to look great along
the way
um and if you're like think about like
the stock market
if you've got a stock that all of a
sudden is controversial
is that the time to sell it or do you
kind of want to wait till things maybe
flush out a little bit and see what what
kind of value you get after the fact
because right now to me
desean watson's trade value is pretty
low
so if you're the houston texas why would
you sell so low
and trade for so little when it really
isn't ultimately going to impact your
season one way or the other
i i don't understand why the texans
would trade for him nor do i understand
why another team
would make that deal either yeah it's
it's difficult for me to understand
where that would go and then
just the uncomfortability of him i mean
i know the head coach talked about how
he hasn't been a distraction or
everything but i mean he's he's not in
the picture right he's made it very
clear that
that a i want don't want to be here and
b with all the allegations makes it
pretty unlikely that
he's going to be an eligible player most
likely if the commissioner decides to
put him on a list of of some sort so
this is
tyrod taylor's team maybe leading into
ultimately davis mills's
uh the rookie quarterback out of
stanford but i i i mean it just
it it just seems so chaotic in the wake
of
a new head coach and everything moving
forward yeah and i think that players
sometimes subscribe to the belief or or
the agents of those players that
if we create chaos then we'll cause the
team to just want to get rid of the
problem right
but we just saw with aaron rodgers like
green bay weathered the storm of the
offseason
and ultimately now has number twelve a
whole thing quarterback
under center for them this season so i'm
not saying that the texans are
weathering the storm to eventually have
watson as their quarterback but they can
certainly whether the distraction to get
proper trade compensation for him
once we know what his punishment
ultimately will be if what
if the nfl decides to levy it and once
we have some better understanding
of of the actual by the way the
important 22
civil lawsuits that are currently out
there against him all right
um less than a week from the first
preseason nfl game to be kicked off
there in canton ohio next thursday night
um i i you know i just kind of asked
this question to anybody i've been
talking to who
who covers the nfl and who's been around
i mean it
we got through a season last year but it
it didn't quite feel the same
what is it what are you how are you
feeling right now you know less than a
week away from
from from us to to get rolling i was
super stoked like
three or four weeks ago and and i think
i
i'm excited to just like be back in the
mix and on the field and feel the fans
like that's the stuff that i love the
most about the job i'm obviously
probably like a lot of people wondering
um are we headed
in a direction that's going to cause
once again this
to be a weird season right but uh but
man i i hope
because last year was weird it was so
even for us
sports reporters that i realized fans
don't care about us nor should they
but like just the energy all the things
that we we all love about football just
wasn't there yeah you watched it on tv
and they did a good job with the crowd
noise and all that stuff
but it just wasn't the same and uh and i
i just can't wait for it to get back to
that
well before we let you go here uh my
friend chris brockman
brought to my attention your your
fishing expertise
and uh and this this behemoth
that that you you know brought into your
boat
um tell us about this 91 pounds is that
was that right
i'm not so much the expert i do i'm the
guy that people call because i'll i'll
drink a bunch of beers and have a good
time
everybody on celebrate when we catch the
fish right but uh but yeah we caught a
91 pound black
grouper which for fishing people uh
they'll understand that a black grouper
is a
a pretty coveted fish that's awesome to
eat and
it's uh it that's a really big that the
the key west marina where we had we
brought it in to have the
it weighed uh it broke their record by
about 41 pounds no way so yeah
we're talking about we're talking about
a
monster we've been so this is this is
this is patrick mahomes this is an
anomaly like
out of nowhere just uh the phoenix rises
this is the big boy
this is the guy we were we were chasing
we were looking for one
and uh after like we do this trip every
year for like 20 years
with my college buddies we go to dry
tortugas which is like 70 miles west
key west and we like sleep on the hall
of the boat for three nights
and like once in a while we'll try to go
get a black grouper
in like deeper water uh this year we
went and uh
we thought it was either a shark or an
amberjack but the guy we were fishing
with was like you always got to fight
like fight it like it matters
and all of a sudden that black roofer
pops up and we just went
we were swimming nuts it was awesome no
i'm a fisherman too right i i'm a fly
fisherman i grew up in montana so i'm a
riververse run through it i'm uh
you know you know i give me my 8 to 12
inch uh
you know cut throat and i'm a happy
camper if i had a reeled in a 91 pound
black grouper right
i might i might have put the retirement
uh uh speech out there
it's all it's all relative to though you
know like you can get i thought uh
amberjack for
like like the monster amberjack for an
hour and you get it up and it's a reef
donkey and you're like oh
crap i just wasted all my energy for
that
amazing how different species get you
more excited than others pretty wild
yeah well it's it's cool to follow uh um
miss seeing you around the office out
there uh in connecticut uh
excited for football to be back really
glad you could spend some time with us
today
keeping us uh abreast of everything
that's going on jeff darlington
everybody espn nfl reporter
thanks again for joining us bud all
right later
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here